all I have to say is this my
relationship with my body hair is a
interesting saga I remember being in
preschool and kids making fun of me
calling me a werewolf I went through
puberty a little bit earlier than most
people I swam in t-shirts I wear sweat
pants to pee every day if I was taking a
shower a holodeck didn't even want my
family seeing never shaved my body hair
this much I hope that I can carry what
I've learned about myself and accepting
Who I am well I'm a confident man I
think I could pull off hairy or smooth I
think going to definitely be one to
remember
personally I probably haven't shaved my
legs in six months but I know how to
shave let's do this I think there is a
stigma with women are supposed to have
smooth legs and arms hairless armpit
[Music]
I have a double standard for a man
shaving a woman shaving the third day I
think is gonna be most interesting my
skin color is so weird
I've never seen it without a hair like
this it definitely missed some spots
yeah like that that's there how many
times you touch your arms today so many
they're so naked Tuesday when my leg
hair started to grow when I couldn't
sleep it's 3:00 a.m. so itchy
I don't want to be swimming I loved
rubbing my legs together I am doing this
for the rest of the night so I just got
back from a workout class I feel like I
could go faster I don't know if I was
just in my head but science wise should
be correct
I miss my arm here
Lumis monthly care I know I can get
ready in 15 minutes
and be out the door just showered now
going to do my final shaving I mean that
will double triple the time of your
shower shaving has been an experience to
say the least my favorite part about it
was right after you shave for the first
time I love how it feels it's like so
saw it was weird cuz I was getting some
looks cuz my arm hair it's not fully
grown back yet and it's not super smooth
a lot of people actually didn't notice
that I had done anything until I would
point it out to them
they were pretty supportive people liked
it actually they said it made my arms
look skinnier and my calves more defined
I don't know why society puts such a
pressure on on body here I can't imagine
having to do this all the time at the
end of the day if you don't want to do
it you shouldn't have to it should be
your own personal choice what's on the
inside the pants whether your hair your
smooth you could be masculine or not
being a hairy guy I say grow with the
flow
[Music]